Spider-Man No Way Home is back
in theaters who's coming with me
catch it on the big screen i'm in with new footage
we should do this again you got it spiderman
no way home. Welcome back everyone this will be
my brand new spiderman no way home extended cut
trailer video with a bunch of deleted scenes they
have 11 new minutes of footage that they worked
into the extended cut it's coming out in theaters
really soon as the trailer says a couple of those
deleted scenes are in this trailer literally so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos of course i'll do like a really big video
for all the deleted scenes when they release it
because it's happening so soon we'll do a giveaway
for movie tickets all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite deleted
scenes so far they've actually revealed a bunch
of them like the first one in this new footage is
peter in gym class the day that he came to school
after matt murdock daredevil helped him clear him
of any charges but the secret had officially come
out like the genie was out of the bottle so to
speak so like all the other kids in school here
in gym class are egging him on to crawl on the
walls show off his powers which he does there's
another new scene of mj helping them during their
final fight at the statue of liberty with the
sinister six characters where she throws them the
canister there's another really cool scene during
the final fight where andrew garfield spider-man
talks to toby mcguire spider-man and tom holland
saying that they should do this again sometime
seems very leading just teasing another major
multiverse spider-verse crossover which now based
on what they've announced so far for marvel phase
5 and marvel phase 6 seems like more of an
avenger 6 secret wars teaser than anything else
because i think based on what we've learned about
the spider-man character so far like in the next
couple of phases spider-man 4 kind of seems like
it's going back to the basics and doing him more
as like a friendly neighborhood spider-man level
character instead of being like a giant avengers
crossover like there'll be other characters
in spider-man 4 of course it'll be a big movie
but like matt murdock daredevil will probably
be one of the big crossover characters and he's
another ground level character so for those of you
wanting to see both of those characters together
on screen more it sounds like they have plans for
that i don't know if that means that spider-man
is gonna have any cameo scenes during daredevil
born again maybe but i'm not expecting it they're
like a billion other big characters that they have
plans for to cameo in daredevil born again then we
have a new scene of spider-man stopping a criminal
early in the movie who's played by tom holland's
real-life younger brother harry holland it's meant
to be the scene where his advanced suit the jack
kirby suit that he made in spider-man far from
home gets the paint thrown on it we see footage
of that in the background and he winds up having
to turn it inside out when they go after electro
because he can't get it off so it becomes the
black suit but it was really just like the same
suit just inside out it was also kind of meant to
be a cool wink in the direction of the black venom
suit because they also have the piece of the venom
symbiote that they leave on earth 616 at the end
of the movie so also symbiote saga happening for
him sometime soon maybe not in spider-man 4 but
definitely in the new trilogy of spider-man movies
at some point hopefully when they get to avengers
6 secret words they'll culminate that storyline
and has some easter eggs for the way that he got
the costume in the secret wars comics back in the
80s like i said it's only a small fraction of the
deleted scenes but the first big thing that you
can see that they filmed was a scene where toby
maguire spider-man fought green goblin on his
glider the same way that andrew garfield fought
his villain electro from amazing spider-man 2 like
toby maguire and andrew garfield each had moments
during the big final fight of the statue of
liberty where their versions of spider-man fought
their villains from their movies in one of the
biggest complaints after the movie there weren't
many complaints because it was a great movie but
one of the things people wished they had done was
have some kind of scene with tobey maguire and
willem dafoe's green goblin just to acknowledge
all the history that they have between the
two of them i've been like a father to you
be a son to me now to be fair they did reference a
lot of the green goblins storyline from that first
spider-man movie earlier in the film when they
were all meeting each other inside dr strange's
prison cells just realizing that each of
them had died in their original universes
without completely understanding it right away
you know i'm something of a scientist myself
it is cool to see that they actually did film
a tobey maguire vs green goblin scene but for
whatever reason it just didn't make the final cut
i'm assuming that's because they were turning this
big statue of liberty fight into an avengers
endgame final battle situation like during end
game the final battle no joke is like 30 minutes
long and i think they didn't want the statue
of liberty fight to go on for that long because
they wanted to get on to the moment where doctor
strange had to weave his second spell where you
see all of reality tearing all around them and the
first spell that they still haven't fixed yet is
bringing all those extra sinister six multiverse
villains to the main mcu earth there were so
many deleted versions of this final battle too
there were versions where they had america chavez
who's going to show up during doctor strange too
in this final fight but that was when they were
doing spiderman no way home before they were going
to release doctor strange multiverse of madness
that happens with all the marvel movies like
really early on when they start boarding out all
these fights and trying to figure out what the big
action scenes are going to be the special effects
people actually have to start on those before they
start actually filming the movie because they
take so long to complete and a lot of times
they'll start working on these big fight scenes
and conceptualizing them before they've locked
down all the characters that are going to be in
the movie so they have to do a bunch of different
versions just depending on what winds up working
out through the actual filming process but the
next big deleted scene is of the sinister six just
being this awkward squad together like all casual
like as if they're not all evil genius super
villains from alternate universes just me and
the boys riding casually in the elevator if you
haven't watched spider-man 2 with tobey maguire
in a long time this is very obviously meant to be
a reference to the infamous elevator scene where
spider-man is forced to take the elevator instead
of web slinging away like he normally would
it rides up in the crotch a little bit too like
each of these villains can either fly transport
themselves through power lines jump from building
the building using their many octopus arms but
they're reduced to riding in an elevator like
common people the way they actually cut this in
the film like the jump cut to them just walking
into happy's apartment was a little funny and
i think just because of the comedy of having them
all hang out in the apartment together dr octopus
commenting on how ridiculous all was probably
felt like enough that's why they probably got
rid of this elevator scene it just felt too extra
but if there's anything that i'd like to see more
of it's just the energy of them interacting with
each other all the sinister six villains like
when they were in the cells it was probably one
of the funniest parts of the film the next big
deleted scene is actually a matt murdock daredevil
deleted scene and it's him defending happy hogan
later in the events of the film and being his
very good lawyer so to speak in this board room
like he told happy hogan you're gonna need a very
good lawyer because damage control is definitely
gonna sue you let's see what he has to say
matt you're gonna need a really good lawyer
how did you just do that i'm a really good lawyer
these people in the boardroom that are grilling
the two of them are the damage control lawyers and
they're suing happy for stealing the stark tech
even though if you think about it it's weird
for damage control department of the government
to sue happy when the stark tech actually
belongs to stark industries so pepper potts
could always say oh you know it's happy please
don't sue him just bring the tech back they did
actually film a scene with a young version of
morgan stark from avengers end game obviously
she's a couple years older at this point but she
was going to be in the film as part of all these
scenes with them grilling happy about the stolen
stark tech there is a much longer version of this
matt murdock daredevil deleted scene i'll do a
video for that when they release it officially
she might wind up showing up later in this
scene and if it wasn't clear happy would
have had to stolen iron man's arc reactor
in the 3d printer before all the stuff with
mysterio's video went down and j jonah
jameson started his spiderman broadcast
so somewhere in the aftermath of their big fight
with mysterio happy coming back to his apartment
and things sort of settling for a brief hot second
before mysterio's video happy would have taken
this extra arc reactor in the 3d printer to his
apartment the old 3d printer that he had during
spiderman far from home that they used to make the
advance suit on the jet got blown up by mysterio
and if he didn't spot it the ark reactor that
he stole is the iron man mark vi reactor that
he created at the end of iron man 2 with the new
element and then used again during the avengers
movie there were also a lot of references with the
arc reactor and dr octopus's fusion reactor and
if you don't remember dr octopus crushed the ark
reactor during the big final fight destroying it
the power of the sun the power of the sun in the
palm of my hand it looks like there are a bunch
of other deleted scenes with each of the sinister
six films during this final fight they filmed so
much extra footage for all these fights at the
statue of liberty and just whittled it down to
the essentials for this theatrical version they
talk a lot about how they upgraded toby maguire
and andrew garfield's spider-man suits from their
movie with the modern materials and enhancements
just to make them more practical to actually walk
around in all day while they were filming same
thing for willem defoe's green goblin armor it's
crazy how important zippers are for these super
suits like back in the day 20 plus years ago they
didn't have zippers like this so they were just
way more uncomfortable to wear which is why the
costume department is saying that each of them
toby mcguire andrew garfield tom holland were
jealous of each other's suits tom holland actually
said that toby mcguire and andrew garfield suits
were both way more comfortable to wear than his
mcu spider-man suits i think that's mostly because
toby and andrew's suits are much more cloth-based
way more low-fi which is what he does with the
brand new spider-man suit at the end of the movie
the whole idea with that suit is that it's meant
to look much more like toby's and andrew's suits
he was inspired by their suits after spending
so much time with them that's why his new
spider-man symbol even though the whole suit the
spider-man symbol looks more comic book accurate
looks much more like andrew garfield's in toby
mcguire's spider-man symbol and their suits but if
it wasn't clear even though it is like the comic
book friendly neighborhood spider-man version of
the suit now much more comic book accurate he did
cannibalize some parts from the old advanced suit
to make it that's why you see some of the scraps
from the advanced suit like the mask itself
i think is still mostly the mask from the advanced
suit so the irises for the eyes will still work
the same way speaking of matt murdock daredevil
in marvel phase four it'll be the same thing for
him when he comes back as full on daredevil like
they'll give him a new costume that'll be a little
bit more comic book accurate but also using modern
materials so it's just much more comfortable for
charlie cox to walk around in all day when he's
filming we also learned a little bit more about
what's going on with the spiderman freshman year
series i've done a trailer video from that from
comic con so i'll post a link at the end of this
for that and my full she-hulk episode 2 video also
posting later this week so be sure to enable
alerts for my channel so you don't miss that
links down in the description below for all my
she-hulk episodes everyone click here for my full
house of the dragon episode 1 video and click here
for that spider-man freshman year teaser trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!